احياء مسحت تماما مبان سكنيه ومخيمات لجوء
سويت بالارض وشكل حياه اختفى من مناطق
واسعه من القطاع خلال نحو 100 يوم من
الغارات والقصف الذي نشر الموت في كل مكان
من تستهدف اسرائيل في قطاع غزه
وبالاصح من وماذا تستهدف بمرور ثلاثه
اسابيع على الحرب كشفت تسري
ان الحكومه ووزاره الاستخبارات يبحثان سبل
اجبار الفلسطينيين على مغادره القطاع من
يبقى منهم حيا على الاقل فالهدف كما يبدو
قتل الحياه
برمتها حتى ساعه اعداد التقرير استشهد
قرابه
23 الف شخص وجرح اكثر من 50 الفا والمجهول
هو المفقودون والجثث تحت انقاض الاف
المباني بدايه قتلت اسرائيل المستقبل
حاصرت الوحدات المتوغلة
على
الحياه تقدر الامم المتحده ان
77% من المستشفيات خرجت عن العمل ومن بين
ضحايا اسرائيل مدارس القطاع قرابه
104 مدارس هدمت بالكامل وتضرر نحو 70%
منها بشكل كبير بحلول منتصف ديسمبر كانت
قوات الاحتلال قد القت على القطاع اكثر من
تسعه
الف قنبله ودمرت ما يقارب
40% من المنازل في تقديرات اوليه واختفت
عن الخريطه احياء باكملها ولم تعد صالحه
للحياه ويقدر ان اكثر من
33 في من سكان القطاع محيت جدران بيوت
احتضنتهم واذقه احياء رسمت ذكريات
هنا بيت لاهيه ولها من اسمها نصيب قبل
الساس ع من ديسمبر تاريخ
استهدافها وبتحليل اقمار صناعيه قدرت
اسوشيتد بريس ان ثلثي مباني شمال القطاع
دمرت وان ربع المباني في الجنوب اختفت
[موسيقى]
كليا في حربها على القطاع حاولت اسرائيل
قتل
الحقيقه يشكل الصحفيون هدفا دائما استشهد
منهم
العشرات سيحتاج قطاع غزه لما بين سبع الى
عشر سنوات لازاله الركام فيما بتات يعرف
قتل
المباني التعبير المشتق من اللاتينيه دومي
سيد وتعني الاستهداف الممنهج لاحداث دمار
شامل في المنازل
والمبي